[Music]
hey everyone I'm here with Mark Abbott
and mark welcome how's it going for you
so far great wonderful event glad to be
here
so what areas of research are you
specifically focusing on
well most ocean observing systems are
really like the artisanal cheese
industry it's one off it's for a very
special purpose used once answer a
science question put on the Shelf we
really want to bring that sort of
intelligence all the way from the cloud
down to those systems so that they're
smarter they're more flexible really
make that innovation much more rapid
what specific area of research are you
focusing on now and what problem are you
trying to solve well one of the most
exciting projects were involved with is
called the oceans Twilight Zone it's a
part of the ocean Oh from maybe 300 600
feet down to about 3,000 feet
it's a vast ocean ecosystem we know very
little about it what we think is there
might be maybe a hundred times the
amount of biomass in that world part of
the ocean then is harvested every year
and what we want to do is to bring new
technology to really make it transparent
make everybody not just the science
community but normal people begin to see
that and sort of see that in real time
how do you feel about attending the
Microsoft research faculty summit and
what have you learned well what's really
exciting is to see all the advances
Microsoft has made and really not just
looking at the office productivity or
databases but really looking at that
end-to-end knowledge ecosystem so that
everybody can begin to participate from
sensors all the way up to high end
modeling to engagement and learning and
teaching
so looking out into the future what's
one of the key areas of research that
you're hoping to focus on to drive
disruption so one of the biggest ones is
lowering the barriers to innovation most
scientists have a great idea and they
have to build their entire system the
power the pressure housing the data
system how can they actually just focus
on where they bring their unique skills
and leverage this whole vast ecosystem
of design and materials so that they can
get their ideas out in the ocean faster
hey mark thank you so much for your time
thank you very much it's a great event
[Music]
[Applause]